[Music]
hey guys i'm denny direct oh and welcome
to the daily denny we are actually live
right now so anything happen but thank
you for joining us here on Facebook
watch and YouTube I got a really special
guest for us today and let's just get
right to it cuz I'm so excited she's
here please welcome miss Tara Lipinski
[Applause]
we're here to talk about wedding cake
championship yes season finale next week
I know you guys probably have a lot of
questions for Tara please leave them in
the comments section we'll get right
here to the iPad and we'll what well ask
them as they come but I'm gonna kick
things off I think because the show is
so fun you guys seem like you're having
so much fun here of course hosting with
Johnny weird how can I not have I mean I
mean is it as fun as it looks on TV
it really is I mean Johnny and I are
main gig is obviously figure skating but
throughout NBC we were able to to like
move out branch out and you know show up
at the Super Bowl or show up at you know
me and the dog show and the Oscars so
we've really sort of been able to like
try new things which you would never
think as figure skating analyst so
coming onto this show we were like why
not you know we just kind of flow with
it and it was really fun obviously
there's a link with the competition and
we loved that part of it when we walked
away we were like this was a real
competition and there was so much drama
cuz you never know really what to expect
with the shows and you're like how could
this possibly happen during a judging
like the top of the cake just fell off
and plopped on the floor like that was
timed perfectly right that you can train
and they you know also it's all these
bakers coming on having to build and
create these amazing wedding cakes for
real-life couples in the you know a
condensed amount of time and there's all
this drama and pressure and it was
really fun to sort of watch over the
weeks it unfold I mean you guys know a
thing or two about competition obviously
but aren't you glad you're hosting it
and not the judges though cuz I feel
like that's a tough gig we were so
excited about that because a lot of
people be like oh you're not judging or
Gatica and we're like no like it was so
much fun to host and be part of it and
then not have to be put on the spot as
we always are to critique something but
you know the one bad thing was is like
we didn't
well I did so this is what happened so
all the judges get to taste the cake
obviously that's part of the competition
competition said we were you know on a
tight schedule and afterwards I was like
okay I'm not tasting any cake this is a
problem so I like hit a little fork like
right as they were done I was like
eating the rest of their cakes I ate so
much cake during this process I think
you earned it
I agree I just was like this is gonna
happen you know I have to you don't have
to live it and breathe it and like
there's no self-control when you're
around any dessert you know you just
have to go well you enjoy obviously
people are realizing what a great team
you guys make they want to put you on
every show I mean is it cool to go
through stuff like this with someone
like Johnny someone you've known for so
so long and obviously you guys have
built such a special report yeah I can't
I really can't imagine working without
him we do a lot of things separately but
it's so much fun to be able to work with
your best friend and it's it's a real
genuine friendship we have you know and
it's I think it's hard that's hard to
come by on television or pretty much any
line of work you know to be able to to
match with someone so perfectly as
Johnny and I have and to know that
someone always has your back and
sometimes I just get confused like the
line of fun and work which was I guess a
good thing actually get to spend a lot
of time together off-camera - we do
we're like inseparable like adjoining
rooms and yeah always like coming into
the hotel like what no adjoining rooms
what are we gonna do well you know your
husband is on the season finale and in
the the preview that I saw you guys were
mentioning Johnny's part of the family
he's like you know it's like he part of
the family at my wedding he you know he
spoke and did this amazing speech but
he's always so funny cuz he's like he he
will only acknowledge it as this way but
he's like Tara and I married Todd you
know we found Todd together like our
husband Todd this Todd loved it Todd and
him have a great relationship which is
is so much fun so when the three of us
are together we're just this like trio
of crazy notes that's a dream for you it
is amazing yeah I want Johnny not to
like it's happened in the past and it's
never the friend test is important yeah
I mean be honest nor do you and Johnny
ever get on each other's nerves you know
people ask us this all the time we had
one fight and then like Johnny is the
perfect
gentleman like he is like textbook
perfect of like how to treat a girl and
he's also very aware so like we had one
fight where he like left me somewhere
and I couldn't find him and then I like
pouted for a little bit and he was like
did the perfect thing like no I want to
talk about it
let's let's get wash it right yeah and I
was like that respecter the bigger
picture like it yes it wasn't that big
of it yeah I would like yeah let's talk
about the finale a little bit because
again it features your husband Todd in
the final three chefs they have to
actually make a cake for you yeah so it
was coming up on our anniversary so it
was an anniversary cake and we sort of
put him to the task to make that cake
for us and it was hard cuz I was it was
hectic I was hosting and then like
running over and being the client right
and also being on the show with all
these bakers for so long you're like
rooting for them so it was really almost
hard to be in that position where I had
to like critique their cakes and and be
the bearer of bad news on who didn't win
but that's a lot of pressure it was it
was the finale so it's like who won all
the money so I don't know it was a
really fun episode though was it cool to
share with your husband you have a month
sad and kind of into your work like yeah
I love that I mean obviously what I do
he's not a part of you know and then to
be able to somehow find a way where it
you know like he shows up on set with me
and it's it's special I love that well
speaking of special you guys did just
celebrate your one-year wedding
anniversary I mean has has there been
anything that surprised you in this
first year of married life it's not that
different right I don't know everyone's
like oh the first year of marriage it's
gonna feel so brand-new and it's like I
don't know it feels great but it doesn't
feel it doesn't feel any different um
you know we I missed the wedding I'm
like let's go back into it again like
that but I'm it's nice I feel like you
know being married a full year it really
like cements you know us as husband and
wife and it's I don't know it's been a
good year not so special and I saw on
your Instagram that he because he you
say pop the question right away I think
he was nervous and didn't even like say
what he wanted to write but he finally
did oh my god these are the sweetest
thing on our anniversary is so like the
back when he proposed he got real
nervous just got down was like will you
marry me
we've always talked about he's like I
wish I said something I was like yeah
like what would you what would you have
said I'm so interested in like what you
would have said and we've joked about it
but then he like did this whole fun
surprise for me and and told me what he
would have said so that was really it
was fun I mean you could I just say I
think you two are because I I see the
way you interact on social media and I
mean you found the one like in your
lucky girl I don't feel pressure I mean
it's something that we definitely want
and I think that that's gonna happen but
wait you know I the whole pressure thing
is is like I feel like if I ever get to
that point like I want it to happen
before I all of a sudden feel like it
has to happen you know you have Johnny
to take care of you mean Johnny Johnny
will be mommy I mean I love your and
Johnny's coverage of the Winter Olympics
the ice skating competition I also love
the means I don't know if you guys did
you guys get a kick out of we loved it
you did okay I mean you guys had to
bring a little glitz look I mean what's
so funny about the Hunger Games is in
2014 now granted we were only on the
sports network but Johnny was like the
aesthetic should be the Hunger Games
like it's the Olympic could you be the
you know and then finally this Olympics
like people were picking up on it and it
was hilarious okay so it was almost like
you guys and we were deliberate you
deliberate I mean we won that fun and
it's a you know put on a little show
also sometimes the Olympics can get a
little stuffy you know so I guess
celebrity to it was I loved it I loved
it so much a couple questions coming in
already from Helene from YouTube she
says she loves the show are you working
on anything else with the Food Network
um not yet but you never know maybe
there's a second season so Johnny and
Johnny and I had such a good time on it
I think that we and we loved working
with everyone I think it would be a
really good home for us I love that Paul
from Facebook is just giving a quick
shout out to you saying stunning love
yeah so obviously you've been super
super busy and you're actually working
on a new show with Jim Carrey yeah
Showtime I mean I know you can't say too
much but what's that experience been
like for you it's been really cool I
mean I it's like one of those surreal
moments when you like walk on a senator
like Oh Jim Carrey
I'm doing a scene with you like what is
happening yeah um so when the
opportunity came I was like I am of
course gonna take it and it's the people
involved are incredible on the show I
think it's gonna be really amazing so
it's just been this wild ride and we're
still we're filming right now and it
will come out in September did you ever
imagine that your path would oh I don't
know half the things I do I never saw it
that's the thing you just go with this
like yes I'll do it whatever I'll figure
it out thank you
Ivy do you see more acting in your
future though uh you know I don't
actually see more Act it was it's been
really fun I mean if opportunities come
up you know something like that like how
can you not you know whatever whatever
they said I would have been like I'm in
I mean how could you say no to a comedy
icon I feel you know yeah I mean one
opportunity that I feel makes sense for
you is Dancing with the Stars that
something I would ever be in your
wheelhouse like would you be interested
in doing Dancing with the Stars
you know over the past few years there's
been opportunities but it's never just
been the right fit but I love watching
the show and so I never say never but I
don't know okay I just feel like you
would you'd agree know if Johnny and I
could go on and dance together that
would be like ideal so maybe they should
like mix and match the partners yeah but
no you should compete against him I know
we hate that though yeah we do a lot of
people always be like oh like maybe like
you guys and we're like no yeah we don't
go against each other maybe he should do
it you could cheer him on or something
exactly yeah um did you watch this last
season with all athletes I did and Adam
come on so good it was awesome
all of them were really good I grow back
they're all like athlete exactly because
Abby said to do really well on those
show so I was like curious to see how
this was gonna play out with so many
people at the top of their game in their
school there was actually a couple
figure skaters that played tiny Hardy
and so I know there was three figure
skaters you know what did you think of
Tonya on the show I they kind of you
know they were saying was a little bit
of her comeback by being on the show
yeah I mean I I have a pretty strong
view on it I mean I I think you know I
grew up in the time of the Tonya and
Nancy era and I don't know I just sort
of feel like we should always remember
though that sportsmanship is
something to be valued no matter you
know where you come from or you're you
know I think there's a lot of athletes
across the world that have you know had
trauma in their childhood and still are
able to play fair on the field so you
know I think we always should remember
that
no that reminds me of something that
Adam said to us you know you mentioned
that he had some remarks about Tonya and
how she's perceived in the skating world
so it's do you agree that she have a bad
rep she definitely has a bad rap I mean
you know I know the movie you know a lot
of people sympathize with their life and
I think there are a lot of things that
we're you know we're terrible that
happened to her but again at the end of
the day I think you have to take
ownership and make sure that whatever
happens on the playing field it should
be fair and yeah I think I think a lot
of the skaters feel feel the same way
Thank You Nancy and and what I mean can
you imagine what she went through it's
just terrible so because her career
changed from that moment yeah I mean she
was getting ready to go to the Olympics
elute Lee a couple more questions from
fans cassie love from youtube what's
your favorite cake my favorite cake well
i'm a big chocolate fan so anything
chocolate but if you add like peanut
butter okay i'm like them more the more
than she yeah i like i'm like the
disgusting person that we got that and
brown yeah
kara from facebook wants to know is the
podcast coming back i know we have it's
been really hard cuz Johnny's been
traveling this summer um I hope it comes
back because that's been really fun it's
it's so nice for Johnny and I every week
just sort of like it's like we're having
a phone conversation and catching up but
with the show and everything we've been
doing it's been it's been hard to do but
yeah guys I'll try I'll try to make it
happen again into a room right yeah I
think you should probably just follow
him around right get that microphone one
more of the podcast
Donald's loving the Olympic necklace I
was I you know I noticed that too yeah I
mean is that I mean obviously that is
such a big part of your story and your
legacy is that something you still
really cold close to you I do what's
funny is like I know a lot of Olympians
well he's good like a tattoo or
something and I'm not
done that but I felt my parents got this
for me when I went to this past Olympics
and I feel like it's my little tattoo
memory tattoos a little too permanent
for me it's like no I'll remember it
yeah and also like to be fair it's like
a lot of colors to decide yeah well you
know you have said that you realize your
brand early on and and that you need to
be a role model for young women who
aspire to follow their dreams I mean
what advice do you give to those young
women and young men to chasing their own
yeah I think you know growing up in a
sport like skating where you know the
Olympics whirls around once every four
years you're lucky if you go to one of
them and anything can happen and the
chances of sort of fulfilling a dream
you might have had for me it was to win
an Olympic gold medal is you know that
they're slim the chances are far and few
between but a few and far between but I
think that you know what I learned most
was just everyday believing in that even
though it seemed a bit impossible um and
putting in that hard work and never
giving up and all those cliche things
really I feel like pay off you know and
if I had either so many days I wanted to
give up if so many days I want to get
off the ice and be like this will never
happen like what are the chances but it
happens so you just you have you have to
believe you have to believe and just
trust the journey yeah and then also
seize every opportunity you're still
doing Lance from Facebook is saying
Terry you lose class and that's a
long-held personal opinion that's really
really nice but like I mention you're so
busy when you're not hosting commenting
and acting I mean what do you do your
spare time I have a big dog mm yeah um
so my husband and I love to like chill
at home we love to travel so it's either
traveling or like watching Netflix and
being with our dog doublet and hanging
out with friends and game nights and
that type of thing do you guys have any
vacations planned for the rest of the
summer no I'm kind of sad or big like
summer vacations over we just went to
France oh that's right and it was
beautiful but then you're coming home
you're like oh it's over it's over I
want to go back back to reality actually
kind of son yeah that's using a vacation
start over
well I'm so excited thank you so much
for being here wedding cake championship
season finale airs on
oh my god I can't wait season two can we
please make it let's get that trendy
judging wedding cakes Thank You cakes
but yeah thanks again for being here and
thank you guys for watching us
submitting your questions this went by
way too fast but thanks for hanging out
make sure you guys come back tomorrow
for a brand new daily Denny all right
enjoy your Thursday guys
[Music]
you